bonsoir jean jacques rognon ski merci
d'être avec nous alors l'argentine en
défaut de paiement c'est loin d'être une
première n'est ce pas bon c'est cyclique
qu'en argentine
il ya déjà eu des moments extrêmement
difficiles et notamment en 2000 2001
aujourd'hui la crise effectivement prend
une dimension beaucoup plus grave pour
les argentins dans la mesure où elle est
couplée avec une crise sanitaire pour
biais que le premier mort dû coronavirus
en amérique latine + parfum d'amérique
du sud l'âme et d'amérique latine est
une personne qui est décédée à buenos
aires le 7 mars dernier les cas ce
moment là le président alberto fernandez
en dépit des difficultés financières et
commerciales et économiques du pays a
pris la décision de privilégier comme il
l'a dit la vie pour ne pas avoir comme
dans certains autres pays avec des morts
des personnes décédées dans des camions
frigorifiques
est-ce que c'était selon vous évidemment
une forcément une bonne décision ne peut
pas dire autrement finalement que de
privilégier la vie mais d'un point de
vue économique avec ce pays qui souffre
tant vous l'avez dit ce contexte de
crise sanitaire va aggraver encore plus
la situation est ce que l'argentine
peut-elle s'en remettre
bon il ya quand même une petite lueur
d'espoir la crise dont il a hérité le
président alberto fernandez le fmi en
est en partie responsable
il avait accordé son plus gros un très
gros crédit peut être le plus gros de
son histoire au prédécesseur d'alberto
fernandes mauricio macri ce qui explique
peut-être que la directrice générale du
fmi est tenu des propos plutôt
encourageant à l'égard du gouvernement
argentin recommandant aux créanciers
privés qui sont les premiers à venir
taper à la porte du gouvernement
argentin de faire un geste et de se
montrer compréhensif donc la négociation
d'aujourd'hui le les échéances les plus
difficiles pour l'argentine
si l'on met à part évidemment le
l'échéance sanitaires c'est la
négociation qui est extrêmement
difficile avec les créanciers privés se
dérouleront ça veut dire que justement
un tout repose sur le bon vouloir de ses
créanciers notamment et notamment le
désormais fameux black rock on en a
parlé pendant la réforme des retraites
le bon jeu il semblerait qu'ils aient
quand même compris que s'ils veulent
récupérer une partie de la donne ils
doivent eux faire un geste
c'est pas un étranglant leurs débiteurs
qu'ils pourront espérer récupérer
quelque chose des crédits qu'ils avaient
accordé
il ya quelques années à l'argentine
c'est ce qu'ils essaient de faire
comprendre le négociateur argentin donc
et qui propose une décote sur le
principal de la dette mais aussi et
surtout sur les intérêts de la tête
privée donc le tout est de savoir
jusqu'où peuvent aller les créanciers
privés et jusqu'où peut aller le
gouvernement argentin
les négociations s'annoncent extrêmement
difficile mais l'élément positif que je
rappeler tout à l'heure c'est la
position du fmi qui contrairement à ses
habitudes
peut-être en raison de l'erreur qui a
été commise avec le président précédent
un signal et qu'il fallait se montrer
compréhensif à l'égard de l'argentine et
en raison peut-être aussi de l'attitude
assez courageuse quelle prise le
gouvernement de privilégier la vie des
argentins
considérant qu'il s'agissait là de
quelque chose qui devait être de toute
façon la préoccupation première des
autorités argentines ce qui
effectivement n'arrange pas la situation
puisque le gouvernement argentin comme
certains gouvernements européens a pris
la décision d'aider les entreprises
non considérés comme non essentiel en
leur accordant des crédits pendant une
aide alors salarié il accorde une aide
d'urgence sociale à 9 millions
d'argentins donc la planche à billets
tourne à plein régime selon des
estimations 70% du budget argentin
aujourd'hui est absorbée par la planche
à billets donc qu'est ce qu'il va se
passer notamment en termes d'inflation
après la période lorsque l'argentine va
sortir de la crise sanitaire tout
dépendra du résultat des négociations
avec les créanciers privés
et tout dépendra aussi de la vigueur de
la reprise économique qui semble vrai
que ce soit sur ce sur cet élément là
que paris le gouvernement argentin pour
éviter un accident financier économique
et social plus grave encore beaucoup de
questions pour l'avenir sujet de
l'argentine merci beaucoup à jean
jacques a conclu en ski d'avoir été avec
nous en direct sur les frontons nous
avoir apporté votre analyse